hold your breath
we're going under what you're seeing are
two lakes in the lake district
on the left the pristine waters of lake
buttermir
with flora and fauna that's 11 000 years
old
the murky weed-filled lake on the right
used to look the same
but then this arrived
this is new zealand pygmy weed
it's an invasive non-native species
which means it's come
from new zealand and it's found a
habitat with no natural predators no
pests no diseases no
natural forms of control so it has grown
to an extreme degree pygmy weed was sold
for use in domestic
ponds but it spread and it's so invasive
it's now banned in the uk
it's killed nine native plant species
already
and once it's taken hold it's almost
impossible to get rid of
depriving a lot of native animals of
their natural habitat and in the context
of climate change when things aren't
looking rosy for nature
this is all something else that's
causing a problem
that's why campaigners are trying to
stop the weed spreading further
into the handful of pristine lakes left
in england
we're now in about six seven foot of
water
at the moment so you can see right down
to the bottom
and you shouldn't expect to see any weed
so nothing nasty
sarah barnes is an experienced outdoor
swimmer
but even a beginner like me can see
these waters are special
we have the privilege now of swimming in
this pristine lake and you want to be
able to keep it like that you know for
generations don't you
well exactly yeah you know our
children's children
and visitors in the future because
this is one of the reasons people come
here because it is it's so beautiful
but its beauty is its downfall because
its
people who are inadvertently spreading
the weed from contaminated lakes to
clean ones on their clothes and
equipment
this could be the summer of the british
staycation and campaigners want people
to come here they want them to be able
to enjoy these pristine clear waters
but they also want them to be aware not
only of what they're bringing into the
lake
but also what they could be taking out
and that means doing
three simple things clean check
and dry so clean is when you've been in
whether it's you
your trunks your dog your paddle board
your canoe
whatever just make sure that you clean
it check means make sure there are no
little pieces of green leaf or ever
and then dry it before you go into one
of the really nice lakes that hopefully
you won't be taking the plant with you
this lake has survived unspoilt for
thousands of years
one busy summer would be a sad way for
that to end
katrina for totsy sky news in the lake
district